how you guys doing happy [__]
february it's whatever it was groundhog
day i don't know if he came man i don't
know if he left i don't give a [__] to
be honest you've got nothing to do with
me steve simone what's crack-a-lacking
from
breathing that high octane for two weeks
yeah it was beautiful you should be
running up and down [__] routes
i tell you why yeah it was way more
difficult to breathe it's easier by the
third day it takes six weeks to get
acclimated but then everything changes
your blood changes your sleep you sleep
deeper i love you know what i miss about
denver and the mountains aspen
you leave your window
two inches open
it's freezing oh [__] in the middle of
night that [__] desert
with mountains dropping people used to
think i was crazy in boston i would
always leave a window a little bit just
a little crack in the window it's good
for you anyway you breathe
when you're [__] sleeping you sleep
like a [__] mama
and a [__] no wonder you die when
you're 80 because you're [__] leave
the window open
what am i talking about i have no idea
how was your weekend you're [__]
happy yeah you didn't when they were
losing you wouldn't answer the phone you
didn't call me i was nervous when it was
2414 this [__] did not answer
the phone i was i thought we were going
to lose he wore his shirt with paula you
should have seen him i wanted a jersey
yeah i i was telling steve
i had i had a jersey i wore the past
three weeks i would take it off after
the game and save it i didn't wash it
was it just the shirt that you said no
it was a jersey underwear uh underwear
and undershirt you see what i gotta live
with
i'm really superstitious
i sit in the same spot i wouldn't let
paul not this game but the game against
the colts no the ravens when we were
losing really bad i wouldn't like let
her get off the bed if we were doing
well i'm like that it's crazy
and then i 100 bucks yesterday because
of the game
i put 25 on the patriots last time i was
in vegas
oh [__] look at you so what are you
picking up that yard stick next time i
get go to
that 20.
you'll go get your five points at some
point five points
gambling debts are completely different
that's twenty percent of the biggest
but you weren't taking action is all
yours
when you went action fifty percent of
the whole job oh okay so when i lose i'm
[__] what i'm saying
you gotta get it together i'll [__]
flip you for the whole eighty percent
you know i got that magic coins heads i
win tails you lose
and they're both kids
what's going on with you steve some old
fresh and [__] making it happen out
there on the road
from road warrior yeah i'm going to
canada what are you going to canada next
week i'm doing uh
edmonton by yourself yeah come on yep
that's a good [__] club yeah i can't
wait to bring pictures of the league
that's what arie said i got yeah bring
everything i got the merch getting
delivered those oil people they buy cash
updates
whatever the [__] yeah that's what it is
that's what it is that's what already
said lee what do you think you're
talking about you don't think might know
my demographic
i don't get together yeah i'm getting
cds t-shirts willy wonka golden tickets
they love everything garbage palace
people they're good [__] people i
love canadians canadians are savages in
their own [__] way they got a little
bit more
a little less uh couth than americans
americans think who the [__] they are
canadians don't give a [__] you give
them three beers and they're good to go
yeah they're great where does cashers
morris live
up there
cassius morris lives with your son only
goes like once a week
right i think he does a [__]
podcast yeah
i was gonna do cassius [__]
morrison's podcast this is what i'm
talking about cash is a nice [__] kid
yeah i wish him well every time i see
him he's doing more yeah he had like a
news crew at his house oh that's [__]
people i can't do dick that live here
they grow [__] men and they want to
sleep huh what'd you do i watch the
superbowl with my phone okay
okay good there's spots out and you're
[__] watching the superbowl with your
[__] family you [__] dummy
you know what i fell asleep
during the game you want me to say when
i woke up don't tell me right at the end
when he made the cash i woke up two
minutes before the catch i looked at the
score
i was like oh no and i thought i had the
ball i'm like oh no
i saw the catch the replay i got coffee
i sat there and i told him throw the
[__] interception it was beautiful
i thought for sure we were going to lose
i would have watched that that was the
dumbest play i've ever seen not one half
time
nothing oh i didn't want we turned on
netflix during halftime yeah it's
another [__] move over here that's
superstitious you don't turn out the
[__] game especially when you gamble
to watch some other piece of [__]
[__] show well you want me to watch
katy perry flying around no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no you
dick suck that's when you give mama i
mean get stabbed
with your new english show you put the
helmet on what the [__] is wrong with
you this [__] when i called him
and we gotta go we're watching black but
this [__] kid like this is a great
show you tell us what's cracking with
those little toes let me soak on that
loose
let's burn those [__] tamales off
turn around let me give you a little
[__] little jew dick stop that
happens after no that's before you're 26
dog yeah that's what you do in the
middle you get her over you play with a
little titties and you make a [__]
suit i mean right
right there when was the last time
somebody sucked your balls during the
game how better would you have felt
today
balls during [__] happening that
would be pretty great okay then what the
[__] you think i'm here i'm talking out
of line i love you to death no more
blacklist during the hammer oh yeah you
get it close to you swap some spit your
finger bloop
make a swallow sword of [__]
jerusalem you know what i'm saying we
got that dick between your legs for to
sit there with your [__] jersey out
like a mutt that you are the sword of
jerusalem what the [__] is wrong that's
your next t-shirt
he's got a hot chick over there i
figured i would have told the circle i
mean with the glasses on and turn you on
yeah forget about it we have sex i know
i hope so i hope so you know
i hope you have [__] sex it's been
two years you're in san diego for the
weekend
and [__] yeah but i'm talking about
halftime from now on no more blacklist
that's right you would hurt what are you
gonna watch the game for you by yourself
for that's what you watch the game with
her for yeah to get put in the work at
halftime
better over with the new england shirt
on give a little stab and smack that ass
put it on work yeah you sure that's it's
called put it to work
everybody's sucking here this ain't a
one-man show you're sucking she's
sucking
everybody got sour cream breath from the
[__] dip
mixing with a shot of sperm
that was a young guy
what the [__] do you think you do at
halftime you think you watch netflix
no that's what you had before the game
gives a [__] that's forget sex you gave
her a stabbing you went to make
breakfast you're 26. if i was 26 and she
sat there at halftime i'm not watching
no netflix i'm not watching nothing i
don't think i'm watching this cliff
[__] explode that's it
what is the matter with you every week i
gotta talk to you about it thank god she
doesn't listen to me you're worse than
[__] uh henry goodfellas i feel like
paulie every [__] week i gotta talk
to these kids they don't listen
every [__] week i gotta talk to this
[__] kid
every week i gotta thought
what are you doing during halftime
sleeping but i'm 52. my wife i got a
two-year-old running around it's tough
to get your dick stuck we got a
two-year-old [__] troll on your leg
but that two-year-old wasn't around
yesterday at that time i'd probably give
mama's a weekly stab
weekly stuff what the [__]
but half time when you're 26 you get
your balls lit all deep deep in nut sack
juice
and then after when you watch them eat
the nachos and you just giggle it
what kind of gum works best for sour
cream broth mixed with sperm that's what
try that sperm definitely several
certain pharmacies
jesus christly every [__] we gotta
talk to you about something the subway
sandwich
this [__] kid what do you do all day
what don't you fantasize about pulling a
hand
yeah don't don't say that we do it yeah
you do it half time you're gonna come
here let me [__] give you a stack
halftime's not long enough
it's like
it's only 20 minutes that's all you need
to get your dick sucked
and to go underneath and leave her ass
can you imagine how good the super bowl
would have been if you've been a 69
during halftime
right on the [__] floor that'd be fun
with your jersey on she would have been
blowing you you would have been eating
that [__] behind and sticking
sniffing that [__] who's better than
you on the super bowl sunday 69 and are
you [__] kidding me
are you fi i never had a girlfriend on
[__] super bowl but if i didn't i was
sitting in that [__] house along with
a i wouldn't be watching no [__]
black list of no magicians
it's probably gonna take an hour of the
podcast well first of all let me tell
you here we go felipe had vegan ceviche
and paula crazy i went off finally too i
called them direct we they
caught them but i called them and threw
it inside okay i said how you doing here
what's up fool i said how's that ceviche
coconut oh it's good fooling don't even
tell me that i go what is this [__]
sharay glad
what is this [__] of that which you
eating [__] ceviche made from coconut
[__] milk
my heart blows i bring that up so maybe
it'll be less on me since we're watching
our weight we had turkey hot dogs dogs
are up with turkey bacon it's actually
really good but i know you're gonna hate
it
turkey hot dog with turkey sausage
turkey bacon he just ruined my whole
super bowl
like when i party on the super bowl i
[__] party i'm sure like i even
called one of my friends like the last
super bowl that i had a good time with
was when denver beat green bay 98
99 oh the terrell davis years that was a
[__] great super reggie white house
hollywood mitch hedberg oh wow yeah uh
stan ho
josh wolfe ralphie cooked it was like
three houses were going i think jeff
ross came by to see ralphie wow you know
that was the last time i sat and really
giggled and there was freaks you know
people were doing blow and [__] it was
tremendous then before that it was like
where i was excited like i went to the
[__] corkies and got like a [__]
quaalude and an eight ball and my
[__] halftime were off on rocker
[__]
turkey sausages i'm disgusted they were
good
oh my god i live in [__] hell here
a [__] jew eating turkeys and hot
dogs with turkey [__] bacon yeah the
other day i was at that place
that uh domingos no i was at the club
and the kid goes what do you want to eat
when you're in a comedy club you know
you don't have that many [__] options
right although columbus is a great club
and the menu the chicken is not bad they
had a couple they have a steak sandwich
i didn't eat any of that stuff i ate
salads and stuff
but the one night two shows in between
shows you get [__] hungry you know
yeah so the kid goes dog i split a
burger when he's a skinny kid i go let's
play the burger so me and him walked up
to the chef we're like hey dog we'll
take that burger now
the guy's like what do you want like
what do you want on because i just like
lettuce tomato and cheese i go [__] it
that's a couple made in heaven do me a
favor put onions on mine on my side
because not how you use you don't want
you're not just put onions on my side
after the fact yeah after you cut the
hamburger in half
give me the raw onions i'll put them on
then put some [__] ketchup on it
guy goes what do you want on it i just
[__] told you right
because you don't want no bacon on it
and i go no well guess what this
[__] put making up my
cheeseburger
i looked at that bacon
and it looked like my big toe the fungi
toe yeah
like the bacon they use and
to put on any of that food
70 of it sucks it's not the right kind
that's why i [__] hate bacon on
cheeseburger a cheeseburger is a
cheeseburger i'm right there that's it i
don't get the [__] bacon on it i just
it's like
uh i don't even know it's like you
[__] like eggs burgers it's like
somebody's shoving their head up your
[__] when you you already came what
are you bothering me for
yeah it's over he cracked that nut it's
half time i was 69 with my english shirt
[__] blacklist you said i gotta go
through with you have you seen that show
oh yeah yeah but it's not worth half
time instead of me and mama being there
by ourselves
that's true
and you're not gonna see her all week
here's what i'm saying i'll see you
thursday but that's four days so that's
why you gotta give her three stabbings
in one day
when you're 26 i could shoot nine loads
in one day yeah a couple push-ups on the
back
it'd only be a minute a [__] shot you
know i only last
but at least i'm giving you a stab and
i'm eating your ass i'm improvising it's
a good minute yeah because sometimes if
you're just 69 you don't need to crack a
nut you just get to eat the monkey you
don't get a [__] crack or not it's
about her you're eating the monkey it's
upside down it's exciting for
that's it that's what you want to talk
about what is sniffing the muffler do
for her because it's just it's a super
bowl
that's what you gotta look you gotta
lick it right we'll lick it but you
gotta put some french onion dip right in
there no no that's disgusting
yeah but why wouldn't you
because that's disgusting french i don't
eat french onion dip by itself why would
i ruin an [__] don't you wanna tell
cream why would i ruin the flavor of an
[__] with that [__] french onion
[__] that you [__] gentiles
no cheddar cheese on an [__] [__] no
you filthy [__] anyway
had a great time in columbus one of the
top [__] clubs in the country
great audiences but one of the best
parts of the week i'm going on jeremy
and lope on the radio station they're
great
but this [__] cat i've been talking
to on twitter this pat shea [__] just
listen last monday i went on twitter and
i went on the podcast and i got pissed
off because some guy was messing with me
on [__] whatever gmail okay it's like
so weird how you have one [__]
ruins it for everybody but then you have
20 20 000 people great people like
talking lair and leon and [__] jason
uh no susquehanna you meet these people
and you're like this completes my
[__] journey like you don't want none
they just want to talk to you and pat
shea was one of those guys that i felt i
didn't have enough time with like there
was always people around he came all
[__] three nights which broke my
heart just buy one [__] ticket yeah
you know it would come your family you
know yeah but uh you know who else is
cool who who who you you men haven't met
yet but new orleans smokehouse he has an
instagram where he takes pictures of all
the food he's cooking we're just looking
at it today it looks like unbelievable
tremendous those people and they're
having a festival they're not inviting
us what the [__] so we're going to make
our own festival i like new edina that's
what i think i'm going to do i knew what
he did before i did
let's take eight of us down there four
or fivers take a big bag of reefer and
let's go deep into the [__] bayou of
debt
into new orleans and have a little
festival it's a hot 99 seats that'd be
good three shows in one [__] night 20
minutes a piece and get the [__] out of
there
that's how you do it me you somebody
else i would love that get three cheap
hotel rooms off the [__] beaten paths
you don't have people playing the trump
bonus
jumping up and [__] down the trombone
yeah no when i went down there shoot
grudge match i liked it i thought it was
pretty neat down i just don't want to be
in the mix of things yeah it's okay it's
like being off the beaten path a little
bit especially that it's a little too
much for me i think i'm a little too
long of the [__] especially in hotel
rooms like where we we made the mistake
of getting a hotel room in downtown san
diego which i'll never do again because
they paid they charged 40 bucks for
parking at night and we didn't really do
anything in downtown so and i just i
should have booked a hotel but she went
to school there so i chose it but it was
way too loud there were drunk people all
night i [__] stabbed this kid for 40
years though my guarantee what are those
rings you got on you got like a super
bowl rung on yourself i got no super
when i got the indians i got my wedding
band what's the indian i've never seen
that before yes you have i wear this
[__] this is my main [__] man
right here oh [__] that's the
[__] indian what the [__] you
think you're dealing with you never seen
the ending there's no longest yard he's
a grudge match oh really yeah i'm trying
to sneak him with everything that's
great i go to the director that's
beautiful all right let's do this [__]
[__] you think you're dealing over here
oh my god so can you tell me can you
tell them about what you you call me
every time you have a connecting flight
and tell me the menu you had for the
edibles at like 3 am you're like all
right dog i woke up i threw a star in oh
[__] i was [__] up i sat next to
what i said next on the way i have
sebastian behind me no way and john
legend
right next to me
that's fantastic
well here's what happened i got on the
line
and i saw them i saw
a delta airline
two guys big guys with a big black guy
and a little black guy i just couldn't
tell who it was i didn't really give it
that much attention right i just look so
when i walked in the plane
i put my thing up and i saw the big
black guy sitting three rows behind
he had a window scene when i looked down
i'm like holy [__] it's john [__]
legend so i put my luggage up and i just
sat down you know how many words i said
to him throughout the whole flight
zero not one [__] word not even a
zero i didn't even acknowledge the
[__] i sat there watched the
drop i watched some other [__] that was
on tv delta the direct flight to atlanta
one of the best flights i've ever taken
yeah you you just sit there like a king
like a [__] king with the camera i
love the [__] camera behind the seat
what's that uh the screen the screens
you pick and choose whatever you want
all
that makes a big difference guys night
and day that's a night you're right jet
blue with the [__] cool tv the united
charges which pisses me off you know
what charges for tv at least in back
they do united [__]
is i don't know last two flights i think
you know i did not have wi-fi [__]
right i don't care i don't care about
your [__] movie but let me get on the
computer for five minutes and do what i
gotta do
yeah at least i can write a paragraph a
book or something you know
they didn't have [__] wi-fi guys
yeah you know
no [__] wi-fi i sit there stalling to
the gills anyway you know me i got the
bases covered yeah so tell them what you
take at three in the morning four in the
morning you take a [__] start in the
chibo chill when i get on the i don't
think they're 210 million oh my gosh but
i don't take the chi i take the star
with my protein shake and the blood
pressure
then i drive to [__] lax i get to lax
i park the car i walk in i check i get
everything and when i'm putting my stuff
through security i put the i take the
chimachu wrapper
off the little cheap machine when i
throw the cheap [__] on security the
bucket
because i don't want to eat it right
then i want to eat it so you just put a
piece of candy in the pocket nobody even
thinks about it
what are they going to do and if they do
that what's in there what are you
looking at it doesn't really smell like
weed but just for reference steve i took
maybe 40. probably close to like 38
something tonight he took five times
that had before six of them well they
told me in denver 10 milligrams in a
bowl
yeah
that'll be nice but you're never going
to do tell me 10 milligrams of joey how
many milligrams 10 i did at least four
because it's 25 and then he gave me half
of the other one and then we smoked a
joint
wow
people keep asking for a slurry leak so
they're gonna get it
i don't care anymore oh he's [__] up i
love it's a beautiful monday
someone just said i love how joey gets
just as uncomfortable talking about
tricky big and as steve does about blow
jobs
oh please i hate [__] turkey bacon
i'm standing online before i know paula
so i was just like uh i'm standing on
line before with two [__] i know paul
two i love playing with that but it
don't matter because i know what [__]
harvey almost doing i know he's sitting
there playing a board game or [__]
playing a board i know this [__] guy
we played monopoly the other night yeah
what the [__] are you talking about
i'm dealing with [__] harvey [__]
whipped esteem at least i won
uh jesus christ the money what'd you win
what's what did you win what did you win
at the end of three hours what the [__]
did you win the big hotel
you're 26 years old
she's mexican put that ass to work they
like that [__] mexican people they're
used to it all these guys go over there
those mexican bang hop bank why because
they're savages those women will [__]
go for hours you don't need to go to
analytical
you're wasting your time friday saturday
sunday you just prank those curtains
black you're the one that wants to be
harvey feinstein and say oh let's go to
san diego downtown then you realize it's
40 a [__] night to park ain't [__]
around down there what were you thinking
you don't understand carl's bad had to
drive downtown even a [__]
four-year-old knows that shitley
a professional next time ask one of us
go i gotta take this
don't ask carl she's gonna tell you yeah
go on expedia what the [__] do they know
what does she know about traveling he
knows he's he leaves the mayor [__]
san diego
you should have gone to him and got a
[__] little place in la jolla off the
beaten path for 60 bucks you just go in
there anyway right or wrong what are you
going through these rooms to do yeah
you're going to [__] anyway everything
in san diego is a distance you're not
going to walk around nobody wants to be
downtown nobody yeah nobody wants to be
downtown you can find one of those
places in la jolla with no air
conditioning for 65 at night yeah all
season like yeah all season that you
parking free that you cuddle next to
that [__] what's the plan nobody
remembers rosarito what's the [__]
place next to the denny's on the pj
romero's there ain't no better mexican
food down there than that i know your
friend has the tacos but they're white
people tacos i'm talking mexican [__]
food mexican food there ain't no better
than [__] romero's romero's dirt
tacos in the middle of the night right
tell this [__] momo but he don't
understand he got sucked in
because expedia she wanted to go who
gives a [__] what she wants one of the
best things about what we need yeah you
don't have to do the next car you drink
for [__] free you don't need to move
the car that's it you're done for the
whole weekend you don't ever go to san
diego for [__] nothing that hilton
downtown i took a pot cookie
200 of the [__] night i didn't pay
for it the club pay for it i took a pot
cookie in a baggie do you know i woke up
in the morning a [__] rat had even
had the [__] pot cookie through the
baggie i'll never [__] stay downtown
but you don't ask
you don't ask you like a sucker
you want to go
the [__] is wrong with you
you go to [__] la joy right there off
the beaten path i'm staying there with
terry a thousand times and everywhere
else is like 200 they want a 65 no air
conditioner you crack that window but
that's the best piece of code [__] you
ever gotten in your life you go to that
[__] ramiros but you know how much
you eat for 20 bucks in romero's three
bags three bags no [__] mobo you get
the best carne eaters in [__] san
diego and a [__] bean and cheese
burrito with a little peek of the guy on
that [__] that's that's what
you're eating well the yelp said i don't
give a [__] what
yep said i'm telling you what the
master's a disaster said you're mexican
this what the [__] you're eating and
that's it
romero's best [__] thing next to
denny's right next to pb or whatever
yeah we grew up there
right how many [__] sets did you do
that's how i met adam hunter i met a
thousand people doing comment on that
and that's the rule when you walk out of
that nobody goes to [__] denny's you
go straight to [__] romero's when you
left the comedy story tonight you went
right to
romero's i got the same [__] every time
carnitas the best rice the best beans
the carnitas were brown
you never got sick but what put you over
the [__] top was that bean and cheese
burrito jesus [__] right david
chevitz first time i got a bean and
cheeseburger right there holy [__]
time that's what excites me about going
to san diego and they would call me that
room paid 200 bucks i dropped 20. i used
to buy
this is how fat i was
i used to get the carnitas and three
bean and cheese
burritos
and
some mercy's [__] i swear to mercy
by the time i got to
i replied
god how big of the [__] bean and
cheese burritos down there bro you
needed driving like that
it's there's no driving lee
they do have a drive in there but it's
not like mcdonald's no no i said you
either driving back to l.a
a humongous it's not like a taco bell
burrito it's a no it's a real
football for i would eat the carnitas
parked that you don't drive
you gotta put them in the taco with the
pick of the guy in the sour cream and
the [__] guacamole you have no
[__] ideally best mexican food
best mexican should order that italian
food from [__] best mexican food i've
ever [__] had that here is there any
mexican food like that in the valley
there's a couple decent places but not
great no right listen
when you go to mexico nobody puts french
fries on carnitas and vice versa
so that's not mexican food that's
something [__] some guy named lee
sits [__] dick wits and
you like that [__] that's not mexican
food
i'm talking about you know where the
second best place i had mexican food
yeah
long beach
oh gabriel took me to a spot in long
beach it was a little bit totally down
i'm telling you that's where you go and
you go
these are some real [__] mexicans in
that kitchen this [__] guy's never
had a shrimp mexican shrimp cocktail
which i never heard about it your
[__] head will blow but
i mean you got crepes you learn how to
make [__] grapes you [__]
at macaroons but you never heard of it
no
you know what they got a good shrimp
cocktail
casa vega i was just thinking about that
i guarantee casa vegas lasagna's like
the whitest mexican place here they
might have a nice [__] shrimp
cocktail
that's a good mexican shrimp cocktail
there's a million of those little shrimp
cocktails that you get aids from eating
yeah
they'll give you five big ones lee
filled with avocado and onions mixing
these things when you pick up the
[__] shrimp it's got the avocado on
them is it cocktail sauce still or no
it's way beyond cocktail sauce for
[__] amateurs oh wow and me i don't
drink i'm a [__] but if i was a young
guy i would only have that with a
[__] corona to do
and tell him to spice that [__]
up like if i was 30 like i like my
calamari and rudy's with hot sauce the
meat i love it the medium burns people
the hot sauce takes you to a different
level but with a heineken on top in the
old days when i knew there was a half
gram in the car stop
stop you pop that [__] two bumps of
blow you take a tremendous [__] you
next time i find that you're not 69 and
during halftime we're gonna have a
problem
and next season you do that every game
like you start that game one paula come
on over what are we gonna do come here
and you
[__] get that [__] muffler that's
nice
well you know depends what you're
sucking on if you lick the ass or you
make completely different noise your
machine kind of
you give that little licks you don't
want to drive it crazy
we really need to have like a
sex but like you need to overtake over
love line give her the dog oh my god the
ratings would go through the roof we're
just having a good time here people it's
a monday night where's tony bennett oh
[__]
you're slipping and [__] what the [__]
we saw yet are you gonna go see him in
lady gaga yeah yeah get tickets tomorrow
morning since you see me all [__]
excited
you say i gotta deal with
when
somebody breaks your heart
some
somebody
twice as smart so we need another half a
star hell no let's get the other half of
that [__]
i do over here because of this oh i'll
give you a ride
you say i got deal with the uber here
oh
i think that was responsible well
responsible he's always responsible he's
one of the best [__] people i know he
don't need the uber somewhere you got a
couple [__] stars in you drive by
sound yeah you just get in the car and
do what you do you always get yourself
home
you even got hit by a cop car who gets
hit by a [__] sound
at the old time
he gave me a jolly rancher that was just
not that great and the sound went down
if you want if you look we did we did up
when like a wednesday podcast the sound
went down when i had to go home and get
a piece of equipment on the way back a
cop's mirror hit my car oh god and i was
like [__] we were at a light that's so
worst luck imagine i was high as [__]
well i'm not i wasn't this high i was
pretty high
coming back and i was like i was just
okay through the window but they said no
pull over into the uh that mini mart
over on on more park i'm okay officer
i'm good i'm good and we got out of the
car and then when they looked and like
it bent their mirror back
they're like okay i was like i'm fine
that's good we're good
like looking back on it i should have
got like a get out of jail free card
i would have loved
to sideswipe the car
i would have taken off and just plowed
it to another
open up the seat but i just put it down
on the street
and started [__] shivering like like
i'd sue the [__] they got
nowhere to go
yeah if a cop car hits you they don't
know where to go especially like if they
run a light or something you just drop
out
you start talking about [__] beirut
in 69.
how you want to hang them high you were
an extra in the [__]
what's going on lisa
everything all right my brother
everything's good well he got planned
for this weekend this weekend what do
you got planned for valentine's week and
i want to hear this [__] disaster oh
you know the store we're doing uh our
three fat foods we haven't been able to
do since june in and out bob buffalo
wild wings and uh pizookies
i think buffalo wings are eating a piece
just like six because we're gonna fix a
piece well no we're gonna share six i
think because what we're gonna do is go
to the movies and split up in and out in
buffalo wild wings but there's nothing
out
at most in two weeks maybe american
sniper but will that will be in
valentine's day saturday what's saturday
dick night all right thing that's
happening don't you don't worry american
sniper on valentine's day you know what
it is
lisa ayant's dick it's lisa that's the
only
you know what i'm sniper
using protection no she's on the pill
yeah all right you don't be [__]
getting that mexican blood pregnancy no
no
that [__] you got good sperm you have
this treadmill i'm sure i do sure you're
eating good you're drinking water
that little juice burger's ready to
[__] branch out you're done
oh that'd be something bad can you
imagine the whole family moving you got
grandma mom oh the mother would move in
the father make a comeback the uncle be
back and [__] you'll be over there
working ten [__] podcasts you'd be
podcast too
you just be sitting at the
that's it you just see it look at you go
to [__] you stream you just see me
exhausted exhausted as [__] oh but i
wouldn't mind the mom moving and she
makes amazing food oh all right please
wait till she moves in she talks to you
every day you'll be begging to get out
of that [__] house and smoking though
yeah i'm sure you're begging me for that
magical mystery tour you move that
[__] lady
right in
my mom would kill me if her mama moved
him and then i'll get pops up here too i
hit the number i'm going to get pops
right next door to you
don't they bring them a [__] package
every three days to get that
[__] going knocking on your door
talking about [__] boston the glory
days
i used to smoke cigarettes and dave
collins
[__] [__] i love this [__]
savage it's the best
oh my god science is tough as nails
underestimates himself
lee we're going to go eat it out of i
don't know
talking a witch
you know guys
i had such a bad life for a while
i know the difference between having a
bad life and having a good life
to have a good life not financially i'm
talking for your life just to be normal
you have to work at it yeah you really
really really
you know when the other day was up when
i was getting to my car when i came back
from columbus for a long time i had this
cuban kid who was driving me
i met him in uber me and lee met him one
night we're doing doug does movies or
one of those yeah doug said to do before
you because you're gonna get high and i
met the kid he seemed like a nice kid he
was cuban and he goes you know i give
rides to the airport whatever the [__]
he said he was for uber i gave him 20
over yeah it was [__] way more than
what i would pay but he's a cuban kid
and i want to help him yeah i'm going to
hit a bonus and [__] whatever town i
go to i'll take that and apply it to
that he's hustling he's doing the right
thing everybody makes money that's it
spread it around money you have to
spread money
well the kid you know every [__] trip
he was always late to pick me up or you
know always an excuse for anyway i just
said forget it i i enjoy driving myself
it's my last 35 minutes in town and yeah
and you know what if i got to be at the
airport at 5 i get that 4 30. you know
why because i've never tried the
elevator yep and the other day when i
got out of the car lee i crossed the
street my car was right there on the
third floor big there was my car
i put my two-piece luggage and i started
it up i pissed on the wall like i always
did
i always pee but at the end of that
thing i don't know what it is i gotta
pee and i'm not going back to the
bathroom with [__] luggage
and i get in the car and i go how easy
is this
but it's not easy because
i got to the airport at five to five
like the old days my flight would leave
at six and for some reason i thought i
could get there at ten to six and they
let me on the [__] plane i stressed
and i kept doing this lee i kept doing
it it was the worst habit in the world
but it all went back to
you know uh
having a job finally and lisa let me
sleep on this couch
and then finally after six weeks i would
get an eight ball of coke blow off my
job and leave with flambe doing coke
yeah
lee would throw me on and i'd be mad at
late [__] lease sucks but it was the
same routine
yeah one day you say this is how i'm
gonna live my [__] life and this is
how i live my life when i want those
trips bro i hate drama let me tell you
something the last two weeks i escaped
major [__] storms lee knows i was in
buffalo last sunday shot to newark that
was my connecting flight as i was
leaving newark santa claus was dropping
[__]
again last week in columbus as i was
walking off the stage they were getting
snow already when i woke up they had
three inches of snow jack but that's the
columbus airport they that's what they
do
yeah yeah they said they all snow's
gonna come they said they were machine
guns they don't they shoot the [__]
snorlay at the airport
as i was taking off
it was [__] the blizzardly
you know but why does that happen
because i get up the [__] extra two
hours yeah and i get to the [__]
airport because as a professional i know
that the first flight that's it now yeah
there's no no no i don't care when
it doesn't work and i'm telling you get
the [__] out always get out that's what
i did the other day i seen them lock up
at the airport
in chicago oh i missed it by five
minutes
i miss it by five minutes wow they shut
a wing off
by five minutes because when i jump off
a plane i gotta connect and plan i eat
next to the connecting plane i go like
actually play and see what the line is
at if the line's cool i jump on that
[__] maneuver position because i
gotta get on that plane first my shit's
gotta be on my bend or we're gonna have
a [__] problem we're gonna have a
[__] problem but it's amazing when
you work on your life
how much easier it gets absolutely how
it's not [__] scrambling the
shortcuts make everything shorter yeah
yeah your friend and this and then i'm
gonna do this better to pay for it yeah
no no don't do me any favors who's the
best guy
that's a fair done it really is amazing
so when you
live it you see it yeah for the last
[__] three years
for five years
i've been telling people
because they know who it is because we
all have those people in our lives
we all have a person in our lives i have
a friend here so every time i talk to
him it's how bad life is but i told him
four years ago to start a podcast
but every time he calls me which is once
every 10 days is how he's struggling how
bad life is they don't know how funny he
is
you know it's just a [__] beat-up
game
and i sit there and i take it because
he's a sweet guy but the fuse is getting
the fuse is ready to go hey listen bro i
told you 10 years ago to do this eight
years ago do this and you sit there and
you [__] make fun of me like oh i
can't believe you're doing a bobcat
you know and
i don't even know what my [__] train
of thought is my nose is getting [__]
congested so i get anxiety
so i started thinking i can't [__]
breathe it's like oh jesus i think i'm
living you got saint jude right there
you got nothing to worry about no i
[__] know that so
i've been telling people for years about
suge knight
suge knight did
something that was like a disrespect to
an art do you want to go eat like a
tissue no i don't want you to do that i
want you to sit there and just relax you
don't go joey i got tissues i got a
shirt on okay as long as you got [__]
the shirt on you can blow your [__]
nose i'm not gonna excuse myself make my
bucket money go get me a tissue who the
[__] you think i am i'll be a buddy
but it's amazing sugar night
like i remember being at the store years
ago and suge knight being on the balcony
and me just getting in my car and
leaving [__] my spot
[__] the 15
[__] the check
i just left when i when henry hill was
at the comedy store 15 years ago and
dice and everybody was out there jumping
up and down
no matter what was going on i got my
come on i got the [__] out of it i avoid
the problem because there's certain
people that they bring this [__] debt
with them
and you feel it on some people you feel
it you felt it on somebody at the store
monday night last week
you felt it you [__] want to get the
[__] out of there and i was like oh my
god felina feel that way how creepy was
the guy yeah when you feel it you
[__] you know the last time i was at
the store i felt it and then i found out
there was a fight in the main room after
i left who fought that yeah yeah the
black comedy night yeah was that tuesday
night what happened i don't know speedy
i don't know none of my business i just
felt normal and i had nothing to do with
that i had nothing
it was in the air and i went what am i
doing on the sunset strip i'm 41 years
old i go i'm gonna go home make a
sandwich and go to sleep peanut butter
jelly i don't even remember what it was
peanut butter jelly on whole grain with
your honey
glass of [__] milk
ice cold milk
you shake it up so it's like a milkshake
when you're drinking it at first people
don't know how important it is to shake
up the [__] gallons shake it up
so good get the milk bubbles but when i
was a kid i had a friend that would
shake it up and then put sugar in it and
shake it up again oh
oh my god make his own sugar milk and he
put it he put it over ice cubes with
shattered ice oh like the gym like you
kind you get it yeah
i don't like milk i don't like he was a
bartender at six yeah he was like that's
chicken he was like [__] ten he had
the that's when the kid was on the
ground they don't put the kid on the
gown no more the old [__] thing yeah
people don't drink milk anymore no they
don't eat milk like that no more so in
the old days they had the thing and he
put like three scoops on and people that
go over the best thing i ever had
growing up was at the bed this house
these [__] would cut
strawberries then put milk over a little
bit of sugar and then seal it and put
the refrigerator overnight
the next morning it comes out like
strawberries and strawberry milk good
googly moogly when you're [__] stoned
you have no [__] i've never even
heard of doing something that's old
italian type [__] they would do that
stuff get the i don't know what it's
called i don't know nothing
but they have a thousand [__] things
like that that aren't bad for you
you know if you eat two [__]
strawberries it's a meal and some milk
it's like eating [__] uh captain
crunch right
that's way healthy
same [__] differences no chemicals uh
sugar corn flakes yeah
how good with [__] cornflakes yeah i
like the rice krispie cornflakes with
the sugar with a
[__] rice krispie treat listening to
them
people don't keep this remember people
used to have a sugar bowl you go over to
somebody's kitchen there was always
sugar there people are scared scoop it
out
and pour on your cereal and [__] even if
you had cornflakes you could dope them
up with some sugar right oh the greatest
yeah you could always dope up cornflakes
because i [__] hated cornflakes but
then i figured out wait a second give me
the [__] sugar it makes my own
frosted flakes hell yeah the best was
kind of chocolate i liked anything that
the milk turned chocolate sometimes the
milk turned chocolate tasted like ass i
think count chocolate tasted like ass
but the other one was good the chocolate
rice krispies yeah oh coco pebbles cocoa
peppers
yes it was especially when they made it
with sugar before and then they switch
over to corn syrup because it was never
the same it was never the same oh good
old school cocoa pebbles and [__] the
milk would get yummy for your tummy i
could eat a box of that [__] when i was
15. i'm a cinnamon touch crunch or fruit
loops guy that's those are my two
favorites you munch them together you're
pumping no i never did that
all right what else lisa yeah what else
you got for me a second that's about it
man well she's gonna tell me to [__]
aggravate this [__] on me tonight
i just came down from the turkey [__]
hot dogs in the turkey uh
that's pretty good baloney whatever [__]
you you love turkey yeah you really like
indeed nothing that's what are you going
to say it's easier to have right now did
you take it to the subway though this
week no not true
just explain to her it's over it's only
jersey mike so we're not doing no more
people were tweeting or saying you're
you're a um jersey mike's girl now or
something she asked me what does that
mean
i said we can't go to subway anymore
because joey said
not joey life said
life dictates itself
you're the best you want the best in you
right you want a nice turkey yeah nice
pastrami nice salad how's the sandwich
at like ralph's at like the deli cake
because i was at the deli counter the
other day and i saw them doing the same
thing mike does the truth yeah
tremendous yeah
it's not just yeah because you told me
that years ago years ago they do the
same thing that just
tremendous rouse has the cheapest
sandwich they used to you can get a
[__] sandwich around for four dollars
that you can eat half of it and put the
other rock and roll ralph and you're
talking to a fat [__] 10 15
years ago it was great i was the one
that went there and used to say do you
guys make sandwiches we'll make you a
salad and they didn't know
they know they charge you for a bun and
a quarter pound of meat they had no idea
so i go in there and get to see the
[__] rolls and make them make a ham a
thuman's ham and swiss with mayonnaise
and a slice of tomato on that
[__] stop lee you don't know
what the [__] you talking about you chop
that [__] half with some potato
chips
and a coke in a bottle not a 16 ounce
that's for [__] you're gonna go deep
with a 32 ounces [__] throw like four
ounces away at the end to make you feel
good about yourself
you even buy a big big big coke but you
don't drink the whole thing you think
you throw away the mouthwash
i won't get diabetes i threw away two
ounces you know saying those are
diabetes
portion control
hey buddy what's up my man how's my main
man doing i'm good you ready for another
star death just to take us to the next
[__] dimension i'm at the next
dimension i want you to put on [__]
dogs
for yourself joey no i say it was a pink
floyd's
how far give me about a minute
speed it up lee
a minute
crank that [__] put the earphones on
took the lights off
i said it's all but turn these [__]
lights up
[__] it don't do that
here we go a little
pink floyd for your [__]
when you're [__] around here get your
phone on the church don't don't put the
windows in the concert we're gonna go
black and white here this is gonna see
you
here we go
take this [__] deep if you're
not doing bong hits rip that [__]
bung out right now you [__] [__]
it's [__] monday night nine o'clock
at l.a twelve o'clock midnight at your
ages i was [__] eating ass doing
listening to this [__] in the winter
making believe i had somewhere to go the
next day
the [__] are you kid crank that
[__]
it's over
what are you [__] nuts
oh now we're going to take you deep this
is david gilmour
i think this is the first one on the
[__] floor the second one metal
dogs
animals
dark side of the moon i wish you were
here i don't know the [__] order but
listen to david gilmore how he takes you
listen to the dogs coming let's say you
wanna acid
the dog has disappeared now you got to
do what you [__] do
you're going to have to get a knife a
gun
well this is a dave gilmour's guitar you
can hear his [__] soul this solo
oh [__] lee
it's a monday night here
stop texting steve from uncock sucker
i'll step on that [__] phone don't
worry but you know what time it is it's
pink floyd [__]
oh [__]
listen to the heartbeat you hear that
heartbeat lee
i'm gonna win some sort of camerawork
award for this boxing
this is to the heartbeat league
don't stop
listen to gilboard taking it
oh [__]
are you [__]
if i had heroin i'd shoot it right now
and here it is after he just drops it
right here
put the [__] light on
put the light on lisa that's too much
that's too much for the human wow
what what number are they calling lisa
give them the number lisa i am hold on
we're taking some [__] calls here you
savages
okay
what's the phone number they're calling
this calling right now
me
the flying jew steve simone gonna do a
couple calls here it's a monday night
what else are you gonna [__] do what
are you gonna do what [__] mindy
whatever
all right if you want to call in it's
818-570-5494
five four nine four
eight one eight five seven four
fifty two fifty four
what is it lee
what why are you sitting there like a
mook on the [__] put the number up
you know i did i did put it up hold on
what happened was somebody attacking him
or something i don't there's a thousand
stories it's a little black gay kid was
saying oh no i see he should run him
over pull the [__] car and run him
over again he ran over two people did he
really run out one die and one's alive
all right so now we should be good all
right there's lisa
here here we go you want to take one
yeah let's do it
what's up my brother
yo
what's up you bad [__] i love
you [__]
i love you [__] the wolf were
you what's up lee where you calling from
he's gone from englewood
oh [__]
well you could just [__] no good you
know that why are you calling well you
can just walk up here [__] suck
everything all right
nah i love it
you just woke me up with the [__]
pink board i'm like oh [__] let's just
let me like this yeah yeah yeah it's
time to [__] do a bongos i don't give
a [__] what time it is get up [__]
let's do the heroine [__] yeah [__]
juice guys
it's all over let me use the bathroom
let me borrow a spoon a leftover one a
little one
what's going on primo what's going on in
your world talk to me papa all right all
right just getting it together this year
you know uh you guys really inspired me
uh was that around that new year you
know christmas those two shows really
touched me so i've been out and about
getting around uh you know getting out
that safety zone
i was uh talking to you about it a
little bit but yeah man ever since then
a lot of things have been working good
you know
it's funny i went to a concert the other
day i didn't have one dollar in my
pocket and i ended up with 80 bucks just
for going out
so i mean i say over to you
you guys for just like getting me out
there
you know and i live far from hollywood
i [__] hate you brother but that's
the only thing that happens on that
couch you get quarters in the cushions
you're not looking for corners you're
looking for [__] dollars you know
what i'm saying so you could sleep
that's right that's right chips like
hebrews like
bad [__]
what else is going on
you see him down there [__] what
happened
actually i was driving by when that
happened i was over there at cam burger
super close to where i'm at i'm like two
blocks away from that [__]
so i saw him [__] swerve the [__] out
of there he backed up
ran him over fast up and did it again
[__] on one or something but i
thought that he turned himself in too on
tmz or some [__] yeah but he's not
already right no he well he might be out
but he's already on trial for like 30
years for steve yeah
like cameron
automatically well no not even that but
the camera one with cat williams what
he's already on twitter broke this
[__] bail
then they might he might still be in
there though
he probably did have that that bond
because he had about like three million
or something like that or something
i read something on there and you might
have three million so he probably got
that bill money
that's [__] crazy that what did he
where i was i was driving right right
there the bill was full
it was like in gardena they were filming
uh the nwa movie so the bail was pulled
yeah it was pulled yeah so post it so
he's out
no it was wrong how much was the pill
2.2 million dollars but it was revoked
no [__] he's in jail yeah wow
for murder and the [__] cochran and
and [__] uh kardashian
[__] robert kardashian is dead who
knows going to represent this guy let me
ask you this when did the tupac
96 in vegas
17 years later whatever the [__] it is
right it was uh it was 97 that they did
biggie and over here over rampart i was
at the comedy store when biggie got shot
wow i've been born
yeah i was at the comedy store which is
really i bet it was better it was a
crazy night i always drive past that uh
peterson museum yeah i always find
myself driving past that [__]
peterson museum
it's very [__] interesting well i
love you [__] for calling
all right brother don't [__] hey bro
listen watching me i love you too man
thank you for doing what you're doing
man from the bottom of my heart i like
that you're just getting up and getting
out of there nothing happens at the
house yeah yeah [__] the house no
exactly you know where you live got it
you sit down
and i want i want all the other
listeners to know that you know you know
just try it you know don't don't be
scared to leave the house get out and do
something it's working for me
you know columbus took a chance
[__] that's right
the sun is shining on you it's a
beautiful day to be alive have a great
night brother i love you with all my
heart
likewise
thank you
hi
uh he got charged with murder attempted
murder and he's facing life in prison
because of all of his committed
convictions
if they were broke that they revoke his
bail so he's good he's in there yeah if
he's in here
that's it
hey man it took 17 [__] years
to get him in there who's next
all right
yo
welcome joey what's up baby boy
this is benny bradley coming uh calling
from southern california oh [__]
everybody's calling from california [__]
i love it what's happening baby where
you at your home you're out your car you
get your dicks up actually i had to turn
it up in the attic today and uh you know
just for the show and made a little
smoke session of myself and you know
finally got through so thank you very
much
my brother what's your name again brent
oh no this is ben reilly bedrock's in
california riley i think he said brent
riley what's going on
you're upset in the attic
by yourself you bad [__]
that's how we do it one with you guys
you know let me ask you something you
live at home
uh absolutely yes sir what do your moms
think you're doing up in that [__]
addict
[__] i don't know i'm just trying to be
quiet so she don't hear me
now how many times have you smoked up in
the
attic oh [__] i'm doing by the bulls and
probably about half a gram so far no no
have you been smoking in the attic for
i would oh well
i don't know i mean just you know
whenever i could do it okay
uh it kind of it gets to the ventilation
sometimes and i i think they're kind of
used to it by now
but
because they you know my parents don't
smoke but yeah it's it's cool though
it's cool though they know what their
vehicle smells like
uh yeah they know what it smells like
for sure yeah
yeah
they've been around the block i used to
[__] have an addict
i used to take my buddies up there right
and we smoke like let's say 27 joints we
get like we get like 25 worth of pot and
we roll up 32 joints like that was a
deal like if you got 32 joints out of 25
bucks you could sell seven joints and
get seven dollars back that was your
thinking when you were 13 and 14.
oh yeah we would go upstairs oh yeah and
nobody was allowed to leave
there'd be five of us in a row how many
would you smoke 25 oh my god from like
two to like six
and there'd be a cloud
and finally one day after my mom died
years later
i was talking to my stepdad in the
middle of conversation goes i want to
show you something
and he took a box
and in that box
there had to be thousands of [__]
roaches
oh that's a style he goes you didn't
even have the [__] etiquette to throw
him away you threw him behind your
dresser he goes it took me a whole
[__] day to pick him up i could not
believe
how long were you smoking for and i
didn't know you know yeah like that's
how long i got away with it for that
[__] addict that's why teachers think
to me that you know what do you do for
work guys
actually i i live in stockton but i work
as a pool chemist uh over in sacramento
at a water park look at you you bad
[__] you work year round
uh pretty much yeah there's a you know a
few months out of the winter where you
know there's some time off but yeah i'm
about to get it started back up pretty
soon here you go little [__] red
shorts on with your little
set you [__] throw the water oh yeah
i think you shake that [__] up
if the ph is fine no pubic hairs
kids jump in [__] it it's warm piss out
totally no cute it's warm with salt
water and stuff you get juice
you ever step on compliments at the
bottom
sometimes
they make you take a shower at the pool
right when you take a shower at the pool
you got your bikini on so you don't
really watch that pre-cum that's around
your jizz helmet right here
you just walk around with pre-cum
constantly
might as well just jump in there and
take a shower i don't think freaking
just leaks out or it most people but it
just sits around your chisholm hole
and you feel like you have like a you
ran into a coral leaf
it's really your precursor
you know fan religious you know
religious listener and you know i just
want to shout out to you guys thanks for
you know hitting hitting the fans back
up always keeping it real you know and
you know we always appreciate it and
yeah man keep doing your thing guys i
love you thank you very much for calling
for smoking dope in your attic you took
me back for five minutes bro i love you
at all my heart thank you stay black and
blessed all right uncle joey all right
it's [__] great i love these people i
love these [__] okay well what
i'm just imagining if like like uh
someone who was working on the show
where like a pretty like a sponsor was
ever like worried about content what
they would think about that
that discussion what discussion
[__] uh
the commercial i don't know i'm sorry i
forgot we were just talking about but
yeah
podcast the [__] great what's
cracking my brother
come on here
uncle joey how much i love you guys i
love you
we ain't [__] around we got a nice
groupie on a monday night very mellow no
fakeness nobody's a genius
nobody wants to [__] tell you what
the earth weighs
it's monday night smoking bong and
scratch your balls
it's past midnight i'm calling from the
east coast i got a 904 jacksonville
number but i live in fort lauderdale all
right
look at you
jacksonville but you live in fort
lauderdale down there so you move from
the [__] mandarin down there
to that [__] hard rock cafe where
steve simone resides
uncle joey's
front row steve simone has like three
residences
over here
florida and [__] denver now he was
just there for three weeks
i'll be back down there they wanted me
to go back in march but i just couldn't
there was too many weeks put together my
brother
so
no we did a good time we had a good time
down there you know i love you crazy
[__] that you said my
girlfriend looks like um she starts nick
with a napkin oh [__]
oh [__]
she's nice looking then she's very
decent
yes you're like you're killing me man
you brought a nice girl to the front but
you still put as part of the show i
thought it was great yeah
well i'm happy you're [__] up and i'm
happy what kind of work do you do papa
well here's here's the deal and here's
one of the main reasons i'm calling and
i'm glad that she's actually on the show
because i know that um back in the day
stephen uh the flying jew there had
their own little show and um
from all from all you guys um you guys
inspired me to follow my dreams
i was at adt securities for 13 years the
big alarm company yeah and i'm going i i
resigned two weeks ago i started my own
company not an alarm business but it
actually has to do with twitter and
social media for small businesses
um so i'm i'm going for it man i cashed
out some of my savings and starting my
own thing and grinding down here
bless you bro you're living the american
dream and you know what you're going to
do well you're going to do [__] well
fast also because
everybody needs help with twitter and
facebook yep let's face it the future so
people you
know momos as you would say uncle joey
that i just have no idea what the hell
they're doing and
all their competition i saw
that are active on social media and
there's so many other good restaurants
and other places that aren't represented
well on there so i saw a big opportunity
in that industry i think that's a great
opportunity that's a great idea i think
a restaurant i i believe that
to be alive in 2015
as a business you have to be on every
social outlet and if you have to pay
somebody a twist for you yeah you gotta
get [__] listen just because i could
tweet i can't fix a [__] bicycle like
if my bicycle chain broke i gotta call
[__] the larry the point that you're
gonna go [__] johnny schwinn you know
i don't know how to change oil in the
car we all can't be good at everything
right we all can't be good at everything
for years i didn't use myspace to my
advantage i didn't know that you could
put on there to go [__] yourself and
sniff my [__] nuts yeah i never knew
so i applaud you brother i'm happy that
uh
i think about that every day i think
about
what day an american
says i'm not doing this anymore this is
great
and how many people don't get the chance
to do what you're doing
to get up in the morning and say you
know what bro i'm not doing this no more
i'm gonna try working for myself and i'm
gonna suffer
i'm gonna suffer for a year but i'm
gonna take my savings two nights a week
i'm gonna eat ramen yep i'll be 69 with
my girlfriend during halftime so i have
to pay for [__] netflix
and you know you know how it is brother
and you do it and next thing you know
it's your own creation and next thing
you know you're doing it for five years
and you're subletting work because you
got too much work and you've already
made a half a million somebody's offered
to buy the company from it's just
amazing what it does and so many people
so many americans are scared to make
that little personal adjustment
for years it was scary yeah i'm not
gonna say it's not man no everything is
[__] scary dog for anybody to grow
it's gonna be [__] scary plain and
simple you're not gonna go from point a
to point b without being [__] scared
whether it's a [__] car ride whether
it's a [__] because some car rides
are slow and some of them are [__]
fast when you go you know bro you have
to live for that everybody wants to go
to great adventure
i got the day on the rides i went down
the biggest roller coaster but you're
sitting in a [__] job like a [__]
mobile taking orders from a loser
from a [__] loser and god forbid the
guy [__] dies you're gonna take his
job and you're probably gonna make forty
fifty thousand dollars a year you still
gotta [__] answer to some [__]
[__] in florida that doesn't have
anything to do with it and at the end
you know what they give you a [__]
gold watch not even and you move on and
you live your life and now you got to
fight social security for a [__]
pension so you know what man at 52 i'm
really happy i did what i did because
you're gonna die anyway at least die
doing what the [__] you love
or at least something that you believe
in
that's that's so big how many [__]
people steve someone after you've
discovered comedy yeah that you realize
you're so happy that you discovered your
calling absolutely this might be bro in
two years you might have 18 people
working for you
do you know that bro that's the goal do
you know that bro in a year you can have
12 people working for you i've seen it
in that media so
bro god bless you i love you thank you
for giving us love and support i
appreciate it you guys keep up the good
work i love you [__] that's what
i'm talking about this is the family
[__] fans i don't want no [__] fans
bro you want to be a fan girl go jump up
and down with these [__] haha go jump
up and down there's a family we're gonna
take over this [__] trust me
this state of mind is the only state of
mind to have suck my dick i'm going for
it if not i'll get a shotgun and i'll
turn this [__]
i just try to tell you one thing man i
was born in colombia but my parents
moved to new jersey when i was five so i
was raised in new jersey until i was 16
years old man we're right but you touch
base you touch home on a lot of things
that you touch on so where'd you grow up
it's just amazing that i came across you
many years ago uh lisa yeah you're
amazing as well man i'm glad that you
two hooked up
simone one of the greatest storytellers
in the industry we got it we got it i
feel blessed that i'm on the air right
now oh yeah i'm blessed that i'm out
there [__] with you we could be in
israel sucking [__] getting [__] in
the ass by midgets and [__] talking
i love you buddy thank you for calling
back man at 1 billion love you guys love
you guys love you
oh my god
that's great those are the only two
options either you're in this podcast or
you're getting [__] in the ass but
made it to this room oh man
you know everybody talks to you about
being an american that's what being
american is just one day going you know
what i can do i really enjoyed myself
moving couches for you yeah i really did
i learned how to take the doors off the
handle yeah i learned how to [__]
paint i learned how to do this but right
now i'm gonna go try this for myself
[__] you're gonna fail i might fail yep
i might fail but i'll never [__] know
unless
i'm doomed to fail i was supposed to
fail you're not supposed to fail yep but
you know sometimes you just picked up an
extra couch and somebody liked you and
they said you know what and then here
you are here you are now moving 18
counts of the [__] day at 50 a couch
six days a week
god bless you brother where's the call
oh no i was just gonna say i heard a
pretty cool like uh
discussion the other day about the
difference between people who write
checks and the people who cash checks
and it's kind of cool like it just it
was just that quick it was somewhere on
espn i think it was something about like
owners getting less of a punishment than
players but i just like that statement
really look at it people who write
checks are better like just don't have
the same thing as the people who catch
the exit that's cool i love you because
you're taking notes i'm trying all right
let's take the no no no
what's up my
brother joey d what's up brother what's
going on where the [__] you been
man i've been here listening to you
uncle i'm over here waiting on you to
call two [__] hours lee get it
together he was supposed to call an hour
ago he's got the [__] magic potion
man right now i'm stationed up in
berkeley california oh [__] look at you
up there
yeah i'm a socal native man okay
but are two things to my call here first
gotta get it out of the way
steve simone what's going on man how are
you what's up buddy
what's going on guys
hey you guys i [__] love
the show man
every morning every monday wednesday
catch in the morning catch it at night
whatever it is man listen to the old
school horn
i love it all man wow
and uh a big thing joey when you tell
everybody when you say tell them all
[__] suck your dick in the morning
that [__] really
translates to because
no i'm just saying that i want people to
feel that i want people to wake up and
we all have this [__] doubt in the
morning i [__] hate it i [__] hate
it
if that doubt was to beat us
we wouldn't be here we'd be homeless
we'd be on a disability we'd be really
[__] fat and when a scooter and
having our nephews push us around
with that little fat [__] without his
head so
i just want to get everybody to say [__]
that doubt cause dawg i get it every
morning every morning i want to stay in
bed like everybody else and say [__]
this and [__] that and let them evict me
but something inside of you so that's
the way i have to translate it to myself
you got to get up grab your balls wash
that [__] good and tell everybody
yourself your dick but it's your lucky
day it's your lucky day [__] you at the
liquor store
every morning when i wake up dog i feel
like i got the winning lottery ticket
somewhere in my body in my mind i have
an idea
uh a thought something we have the
winning lottery ticket every morning
when we wake up i don't care how bad
your [__] life is bro even when i was
in prison i had that [__] mentality
i got the winning recipe today
the recipe is to smile all day
to smile get yourself to [__] smile
all day that's number one yeah because
if you get yourself to smile the rest of
the day is easy
and trust me i got a hard day smiling
all day too you know what i'm saying i
like calling people [__]
look at this chick [__] me off you know
we all get [__] mad
but uh everything
that smile
really does man even when i was coked up
i always tried to
be a little pleasant on myself every
morning so thank you for understanding
where i'm coming from papa
hey real quick joey i hear you always
dropping knowledge
on old school sports
[__] earl the pearl john hadn't
checked i'm a big basketball fan man
what do you know i've never heard you
talk about this publicly well maybe you
know something and if you don't you
[__] have to pistol pete maravich bad
[__] was raised by his father
let me tell you something in today's
world they would have thrown pistol
pete's father in jail but he created a
[__] tremendous bro he wouldn't let
him come in the house he [__] beat
him with sticks and [__] make him do
figure eights with basketball standing
on the milk crate we're balanced on one
hand that's why pistol pete became one
of the [__] that's what they call
that thing the meriviz drill
pistol pete was an alcoholic that was
the other you know he had demons growing
up but his father made him shoot you
know
six thousand free throws a day in the
cold winter jerry wester yeah this is
jerry west town [__] jerry west started
the day off with 300 jump shots today
tomorrow morning go get a ball and try
to do 300 jump shots not shots
jump shots from base up with the hand
extension you won't be able to walk for
a [__] month
you do 300 [__] jump shots in a day
wow but one of my early influences was
pistol pete his downfall was he shot too
[__] much
so if you look at his percentage
shooting percentage you know he shot 50
times the [__] game because he was at
the no he was a jazz
wasn't he a jazz when they were in new
orleans because that was where he was
from louisiana he went to
he was like a hometown state like uh
he's one of those kids that's homegrown
that became a star so he went to a
school in louisiana he went to lsu and
then he played for the jazz oh my god
they must lie and he was a great [__]
white player man but he was a drunk and
uh yeah if you watch if you go to
youtube
and type in red on round ball
and you'll have an episode of john of of
uh pistol pete dribbling doing dribbling
drills
you're lucky if you got 40 times
all right guys thanks for letting me
call in thanks let me talk about
anything hold on i'm checking this out
for you doug where the [__] you going oh
my gosh
stick around hey but you know a quick
story about his dad what i heard but he
wanted to go out for a quarterback
second team right before we played
yeah we're playing where we went i told
you pistol peters down my hands were
extended
this is pete maravich told you who the
[__] you think you're dealing with game
all
all right stay black my brother i would
never have guessed that pistol pete was
white yeah
i love the [__] guy
he was one of my dribbling idols these
[__]
this [__] lease i don't know you want
to take another call yeah we're taking
calls it's early right he ain't going no
where the
the chinese store
he hung up on me he answered the phone
what are you gonna do all right hang on
sometime
what's going on dog what's going on here
what's going on here [__]
hey what's going on guys
it's jonas [__] jonas out here in
vegas
what's up jonas
how are you sir man it's good to see the
three guys together on the show tonight
come on dawg it's a beautiful [__]
night to be alive we're over here stone
to the gills we're about to drop another
star of death
how's it going over there
jonas oh good good man i just stand like
a store uh
just to catch the shows before i head
home that's about it man that's nothing
exciting in vegas
all right well at least you're in
[__] vegas that's it you're going
home it's 10 o'clock you're tapping out
on me jonas
you're not going to go take some oh yeah
man
you're not going to go [__] war
[__] war
stupidest thing i've ever heard what the
[__] did he do i don't know i just asked
do you know anything about it do they
not want to pay him jonas do you know
anything about football
yeah a little bit but yeah i don't
follow it like i used to man all right
you know warren sapp supposedly oh he
got trouble off the nfl i know
yeah he got fired
tell us why give us the story
he was uh
all i know all i know is some [__] with
some prostitutes allegedly i believe
that's the legal way that you say it
right it's elicited prostitutes but for
some he did something where the
prostitutes went and got the cops
i don't know what kind of prosecutor
gets a cop so he must have done
something bad
yeah
yeah yeah he
he hit her
oh he's married we're kids and [__] he's
[__] telling some lies tonight doug
he's with the nfl network
at the super bowl which is the biggest
football game ever he couldn't just get
a girl why do you have to go beat up a
hooker because that's what's down there
is [__] dirty filthy hookers the best
hookers from all over the country
and they fly in for that they charge
exuberance amount for good [__] they
blow smoke in your [__] and
they they [__] brush their teeth with
your [__] kumquat whatever the [__]
they want to do you ever get a chick to
brush your teeth with you calmly uh-huh
they say 400.
memorial day weekend that's how we
[__] roll i don't know steve simone's
available
but he's always available he's always
got a place with me and my heart
and lisa will be there playing the drums
but what happened brother
yeah simone i've been catching your uh
your podcast man some good stuff devin
i've been listening from the beginning
and trying to catch up oh thank you so
much jonas
thank you
yeah
this is good stuff the thing with piper
was great and you've had you've had a
lot of good ones man all you guys are
doing a lot of great work and i just
want to say seriously thank you man for
all the podcasts from all you guys wow
thank you jonas i love you [__]
i'll see you memorial day weekend give
me a hug and i'll give you achievements
come up to me in my ear
jonas
and i'll give you a cheap shoe that's
how i roll all right
all right all right the last time i saw
you i was on my first one ever and that
was a [__] a nice ride
was it a 70 milligram or
180. oh man you gotta ask the loko what
he gave me and it was a gift from my
nephew who came in from cali and god
damned i think he can [__] kick me
for a ride i'm gonna bring you a 180 so
you see the devil and his cousin
well that'll be easy to do here in vegas
man
thanks brother all right thank you my
brother thank you thank you very much
for calling
my pleasure man take care
bye what's up lee what are you looking
for
i'm looking for an email there's no
emails what's the calls okay jesus
christ no it's waiting for you guys to
hang out thank you
i love you guys
they hung up here we go oh there you go
what's going on over there
yo
well i can't believe i finally got
through to you guys man i'm just
watching the the podcast here i just got
off of work about an hour ago man it's
uh
it's surreal talking to you guys you
know where you at my brother
yo i'm in fresno man
okay what kind of work you do
i work at a cell phone shop bro look at
you what kind of phones you fix
oh no we cell phones i work for sprint
look at you that's all you had to
[__] say i got sprint
i don't mind
i've been with you since uh
two thousand and [__] four i'm going
as [__] when i got my first big check
from spider-man 2 that's why i went with
the sprint with no credit and they gave
me 200 limit they cut my phone off a
couple times over a quarter here a
dollar there but we've been straight for
about 12 years now we got no drama and
i'm a faithful [__] follower to
sprint i've been on the plane and the
phonic and phone rings
well i'm going to the plane a thousand
feet in the end the phone is wrong wow
when i answer it there's nobody there
but it gets up there sprint don't [__]
around jack
maybe i'll switch over
i've been in [__] deep places in the
mountains of kentucky paducah
and you give me two or three minutes of
my spring [__] work so take yourself
but that [__] reaches out they
got those martian sprint martians spread
those [__] around here
and what else do you do besides cell
phones over there
uh nothing much man i just at fresno
there's not much to do here i mean uh i
remember you were telling the story
where you came in you did a show here
and you said you almost got mugged by
some black dudes oh my god that was
scary as [__] that's what we used to do
the coach from the high school used to
produce shows there
the coaching the [__] the football coach
he's a black coach
sweetheart of the guy
sweetheart of the guy you know he i last
spoke to him about six years ago he was
trying to branch out he was doing shows
down like uh
one of those things where they trade
[__] things some flea market swap
yeah swap meets he wanted to do a show
to swap me and [__] i'm gonna drop you
off with the [__] yeah
yeah fresno is a really weird place man
you hear a lot about uh you know it's
like the mess capital you you know they
say it's one of the poorest cities in in
the country it's just a it's a strange
place but i have grown up here you know
i'm from l.a i have family that still
lives down there and i try to visit as
much as i can now i would love it if you
if you would be able to make a show down
here you know i don't think we have much
of a comedy scene
what's your favorite next to fresno
bakersfield uh bakersfield yeah i know
they do a lot of shows down there like
bakersfield by sally area sometimes too
all right we'll do something for you
we'll do a nice podcast combination show
up there
yeah i've seen i've seen you live before
though i i went to a joe rogan show in
uh in san jose at the improv back in
2008 and you opened for him i think was
you ari uh you opened for him and uh
funny story about that show you know
that was my first time going to a comedy
show i was so excited just you know just
to see the show and i ended up locking
my freak keys in the car
and i i i luckily enough there i left my
uh i left my window like cracked a
little bit so i had to like
what i did is i macgyvered my uh i used
my uh my
radio antenna from my car to like jig my
um the jig my key lock loose
so i ended up getting you know my door
open and still uh getting my keys and
making it tight for the show so and it
was a killer show man you uh and ari
open for joe and then seeing joe was
just you know it was a it was a whole
ordeal
well thank you my brother we try to
[__] give you some anarchy
yeah
that story he was thinking about
something yeah closing his eyes thinking
about food it's going no i'm gonna have
to go back
you know hearing the interaction that
you guys have you know just hearing lee
giggle you know he gets you get lee you
get lee high enough for everybody so
pretty much there's a milligram to go
around
these are [__] good man brother thank
you very much for calling in and for
listening and for the love you know that
we [__] love you guys do we yeah we
love you i love you [__]
thank you papa have a good night be safe
and i'll see you in san jose or
bakersfield soon
all right man all right my brother
i forgot where the [__] the poor kid's
from that's our president fresno
fresno bakersfield what's up lee how are
you feeling brother what were you
thinking about i'm really [__] up
that's okay you [__] up everything
yeah might be like not being [__] up
yeah it's gonna be nice right now
tonight your limited fee you're gonna go
home watch a movie rub your feet oh yeah
who's better than you no i'm nobody what
the [__] you scared him i'm not scared
you got nothing to fear nothing no man
no nothing you lean [__] say
yeah
hell yeah get the [__] glow get it
together
what the [__] what's happening brother
man what's up uncle joey you know i love
you
man where you calling from where you
calling from
hey i'm calling from las vegas big dog
look at you you bad [__] in the
city that don't sleep number two
that's right that's right all day what's
going on og randy up in the house look
at you hey lee man i talked to you on
twitter the other day i just want to
tell you i appreciate you hollering back
at me man i appreciate that of course
man thank you what did we talk about
hey i just told you i appreciate you
being on the podcast oh yeah i
appreciate you doing what you do well
thank you man you know it's a lot of fun
talking but no thank you man i
appreciate that
man i can't believe i got through i'm
over here like a [__] crack feed on
payday dude
what do you do what do you do for a
living my brother what do you do over
there in vegas
man i ain't gonna lie dude i tattoo sell
wheat out the house you know pay that
child support like a boss
you know that's great i meant that
you're gonna be around memorial day
weekend
hey i'll tell you what you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna be at the south point
i saw your [__] website and i'm gonna
be at the top
you're wearing a joey [__] diaz
t-shirt you're gonna see me up there at
the sound point
rocking that family like a ball all
right that's why i love you man what
kind of so that's all you do that's it
you just hustle
brother hey man i do whatever i could do
i don't give a [__] you want me to pick
weeds i don't give a [__] i'll [__]
do whatever i got to do to put [__]
food on my family's plate
nothing wrong with that my brother it's
a tough it's tough out there for a pimp
hey
it really is my brother hey i want to
tell you something man hey you inspire
me to do a lot of things man i'm gonna
tell you right now you you got me to
quit smoking cigarettes i just stick to
the weed i do what i'm supposed to do
be the dad that i'm supposed to be
much respect to you your misses and
mercy and everybody that you have on the
podcast all the comedians everybody i
love all the [__] you know we
try real hard to put this together for
your people i try real hard with lee lee
and i we talk 10 times a day on how
we're going to make this show the best
we can make it man
you know man and you know what someone
like me it really reaches out to people
like me man i'm going to tell you
straight up it really does it really
does and to get on this podcast right
now this is like a dream come true this
is like a little [__] a mini dream
[__] disneyland i want to be on joey as
[__]
hey man ain't no measles here
you won't get measles calling listen man
when lee and i put this together i
always wanted people to get something
out of it i could be funny on stage i
wanted you to feel me i wanted people to
know that uh
that you know what man i ain't better
than you [__] not by no me and
i robbed i stole i had [__] up
thoughts
but you know what
they hide they they tell us we can't do
it you know they tell us it's like god
man it's like god testing you you know
and we really want to get to that point
because in our hearts you know you see
about these people who are millionaires
they don't help nobody
if i had a millionaire i would help
everybody everybody everybody i could
because who gives a [__] what are you
gonna do with it gives a [__] anymore
i've seen what life is about and when i
walk around i see people hurt you know
uh my friend called today she lost her
job it breaks my [__] all i want to
do is have money so we could give it
away yeah and [__] eat and [__]
get our dick sucked with it during the
halftime whatever the [__] they're
supposed to do and uh
i want people to know that even if
you're a felon whatever the [__] house
you came from you could do whatever the
[__] you want in this country that's why
the united states of america but
somebody always puts this thing in our
mind that we can't do it like we ain't
good enough and we're right there we're
right there with these [__]
they ain't no better than us obama ain't
better than you dawg these [__]
brought that pants on one leg at a
[__] time and that's what i've been
saying from the beginning of this
podcast [__] these [__] and say
you're not gonna do this you're not
gonna do this watch me watch my
[__] smoke
watch my [__] [__] [__] you
i'm gonna do this [__] you know why i'm
gonna do this [__] not only for myself
i'm gonna do this because [__] joey
diaz put me on the [__] map
no no no no no no you put yourself on
the map [__] you put yourself in the
back right when i bet when you're at the
[__] supermarket in las vegas joey
ain't there with you you're there by
yourself don't you ever [__] forget
that you're you're like [__] batman
after robin came out of the closet you
know what i'm saying that's who you are
you're like batman when robin said [__]
it you know i don't know if you know
it's over there ain't nobody sitting in
this seat if anybody's coming the
butler's coming from now on
i love you my brother
keep doing your struggle bro stay black
you're gonna see me at the [__]
goddamn south point we're gonna come dog
i don't give a [__] if you don't have
money for the tickets
please give me your help we're gonna
love you to the day we die and if i ever
get a million dollars would you say
we're in let's go
that's right i'll [__] blood but i love
you to the end
damn right
damn right much respect to you guys you
too my brother doing your thing [__]
much love
rand dog in the [__] house always
good doing your thing appreciate you
answering my phone call and y'all have a
good night man stay black and beautiful
that's right [__] tremendous you
[__] want to make me go out now
and
that's why i said to you love that what
we're putting together is our own little
family it's not about buying a t-shirt
it's not about taking a picture i don't
care if you have money for the show i
don't care if you even come see me live
if you just listen to the podcast and
take that nobody can stop you yes you're
the only one who can stop you dawg this
[__] is easy you can make this shitty
[__] these cuts they just put [__] in
your head that you kept but
get the [__] out of here what's up with
the calls nobody's calling them yeah we
got calls but you're right we're having
a moment with them i have no [__]
moment do you want do you feel like a
national anthem or don't worry so
anthony this is the anthem right now we
did dogs already put him up what the
[__] what's happening
why you hanging up on me
arizona oh look at you bad [__]
i love you i'll be down in april
i'm just hanging out you know uh
a cuban mexican out here [__] phoenix
okay that's from the woman
you know what i'm saying man look at you
came into 79
and uh for what you do for us like all
the viewers and [__] man
it's crazy dude like to see
like you change my perspective
well bro i'm happy you got something out
of it bro
yeah 1985 i believe
he lived in l.a for like five years he
came out here in phoenix
knocked your mama you know
you know you really just changed my
perspective and
how you approach everything in such a
positive way
you know it really inspires me to say
like i don't give a [__] you know i'm
just going to live my life and do what i
got to do i don't care
i just appreciate what you guys do
i've been
every opportunity i get
uh you know it's great
hey listen man that's what we're here
for there you go
there's [__] going on i just uh very
lucky steve simone came on to give us
some love and i'm feeling a lot and
[__] uh lee's here we figure we get
high and it's a monday it's the first
monday of the month and i always like
doing something on mondays i really like
waking people up on monday so [__] let's
do a little calling show yeah
i'm like uh you know 21 but
you know you really put life into
perspectives you know
and uh
it has been really helping me
you know i don't give a [__] what people
say to me now
you know i'm gonna do what i do do what
i love
you know stay here with my family and my
friends
that's all it's about man
doing what you love it doesn't get no
better than that at the end of the week
when you're 50 you're gonna go i'm happy
i made that choice you know
yeah i mean the positivity it's it's
overwhelming at times but you know
that's what makes the world go around
dude
i appreciate you guys very much i
appreciate that you appreciate it you
know i got you by 30 [__] years and
we're having a conversation about life
so how good is that it's beautiful i
don't know you you don't know me but
we're having a conversation we have this
conversation twice a week
and i take from you guys and you guys
take from me and i take from lee and i
take from simone
and we all just get together we're
trying to make better that's all we want
to do man is just be a little better
every week this week i did one more
push-up that's it
that's it why do people
think that that's bad this week i did
one more [__] push-up oh my god that
means at the end of the year you're
gonna do 52 [__] push-ups
but last year you couldn't do a push-up
now you're doing 104 [__] push-ups
wow
it's all about how you look at it man
you just gotta look at the puzzle face
and say you're not gonna [__] tell me
what to do no i'm gonna do what i do
it's so weird how i learn from you guys
man so thank you from all my heart and
hopefully
i'll see you in april if you don't have
the money to come hit me up and if you
at least come down again
what day is that in april you know i
don't have the date in front of me it's
uh april i'm in tempe april i'm in tempe
and i think i'm in houston so that's
great i think no i'm going to try to
make it out there definitely man all
right brother i love you all right you
take care of me you follow you give your
phone your parents love our love and
we'll see you give us all our love
as well man
yeah that's good eight hundred you're
gonna know 800 left i didn't have that
much to eat today what'd you eat all day
i had a bagel with cream cheese for
breakfast and then i had the leftover
turkey hot dogs no bacon but just turkey
hot dogs with a pirate's booty for lunch
pirates booty the popcorn cheese puffs
oh god
they're like the one chip i can have
so why they're not fat
no they mean they're not great but it's
better than doritos
i shouldn't be having him but
you did not push him tonight no i but i
did an hour on the elliptical you didn't
do one question not today was last time
he did a push-up
what day is today one day the second
february
you got it my friend what's going on in
your world
um
you're breaking up my brother
oh one time again call back you got to
call back as you're breaking up brother
brother
yo
hello yo
what's happening where you been
dog
i just been sitting here waiting i'm
calling and waiting where you calling
from
what are you calling i'm calling from
whitney
for where yards is
[__] look at you up there
freezing like a soldier in your little
[__] you're in your little igloo
right now fishing and [__] smoking a
joint
i got um hitting the ball right now to
be honest all right blow a little smoke
for the church from canada hit that
[__] into the microphone
hit it right there that's my boy that's
why i love you saskatchewan rep [__]
scenting in the house canada this is
what i'm talking about
who else sense
i got it i got it your [__] osmosis i
love you [__] the nsa is going to
be here in like three months i don't
give a [__] about the nsa i love you too
i think if i worry about the nsa i'd be
doing this i love you julie i love you
too what about steve simon he's an
officer
no steve simone is awesome panama
i love you brother thank you what's up
my brother how is it doing up there
that's hysterical
it's cold as [__] but it's all right
it's enjoyable if you make it enjoyable
right yes yeah now what time zone are
you it's the state of mind you're in the
east coast time zone
you're in the east coast it's like uh
almost midnight here
okay yeah yeah yeah so union central
baby yeah
it's 10 o'clock here yeah so that's
central to be honest we never we never
ever change our time
but we link up with central right now
okay so that's how i was thinking what
are you doing work up there my brother
i uh i'm a forklift operator okay you've
been there for a long time
yeah about 18 years you dig it you're
happy you got benefits you're the union
yeah the whole nine yards yeah what do
you give a [__] it keeps me happy
you got a nice house i got a lot of
concerts actually do you really i feel
hell yeah
but see we live in saskatchewan all the
good acts
pass over us really like i have to go to
edmonton or winnipeg really
but we do get our fair share of good
stuff okay but we don't get like super
super good
good for you man you're living your
[__] life i love you [__]
you're smoking bonkers at 12 o'clock at
night
you got peanut butter and jelly
refrigerator
who's complaining life is good life is
[__] very lake is beautiful yeah you
have any great what kind of weed you
smoking up there
death
oh [__] you know what talking about
death we're gonna kill this last star no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no so we go [__] straight to hell
uh-huh
so you smoking some og kush what does it
run you up there for an eighth
nowadays if you don't mind me asking for
an eight
forty dollars tops that's not bad that's
what we got in here
you guys living like [__] doctors up
there and i'll tell you one thing about
canada for these [__] jet dogs
that don't know i've never gotten a bad
bag of [__] weed in canada because i
used to go to toronto in the early in
the late 90s and i had to deliver right
to the hotel the kid was telling me the
story how the state grew the [__]
weed in canada and they always gave me
some nice [__] tight buds that were i
mean it was tremendous i never had a
complaint about [__] canada never
what they used to let me in that's
awesome
yeah i wish you could get back in
because i'd go to your show anytime
anywhere but if i can figure out how to
sneak in buffalo
take the bus to toronto and montreal and
all the places that's what i would do
it's getting out they would have a heart
attack like they really take it
seriously like when did you come to your
last week you guys were here no you
didn't well look at the film now yeah
you didn't [__] come through [__]
here we we we we wouldn't let you in
how'd you get in you couldn't have
gotten in unless somebody [__] swiped
the wrong jose diaz yeah and i love
canada i am mad at canada because i
can't go in there i'm the one that
[__] up so now i got to figure out a
way to [__] fix it so yep
but hopefully i'll get up there and see
you my brother all right you keep doing
do another bong for uncle joey real
quick one more that's amazing okay fill
that [__] [__] up out of
respect cause i love you bad
[__]
look at this you see this lee
look at that sounds like a [__]
helicopter an apocalypse now
oh yeah this is what i'm talking about
salud my brother thank you for calling
and beautiful i love you guys from the
bottom of my heart thank you for making
my night tonight guys
god bless i love you too joey love you
guys thank you
wow
give me the coolest people let me give
some shout outs real quick here
my main man josh whipple see moaks
inside the numbers johnny be good leon
my spanish buddy over there holding it
down claire fisher
ray j
and kay razzo i love you [__] pat
shay you get the shout out of the
[__] week like i said john jason no
susquehanna showed up with dead squad
deep from [__] three different
continents he had canada africa liberia
he had some some that squad is just
called librarian liberia
i don't know if it was [__] like
barry let me get a call we're having a
good time here tonight with these
beautiful [__] people
what's up my brother hello
hello what are you doing what the [__]
you doing you're over there talking to
yourself
yeah or i'm ordering a pizza how are you
in the super bowl how are you my buddy
i'm good how are you doing joey it's uh
harry over in brea what's up harry and
bran look at you calling long distances
hey yeah
what's up h uh tell me something good
i'll tell you something good uh well i
just want to tell you first off um
uh
you know thank you for doing this
tonight um
you know you uh you and
lee and steve you know doing this
podcast is great
um
you know i really enjoy it and you know
there's a very few podcasts that
you know i'll listen to every episode of
and you know you yours steve and joey
you know you guys i'll always listen
thank you thank you very much
i don't know if you know this if anybody
else is listening know this
when i do this i put my heart into this
i open my heart up to you guys i open up
like a [__] book and i talk to lee
about it and i want the guests to do the
same i know within five minutes so the
guest is gonna suck on that yeah because
i want these guys to open up their
hearts to you that's the only way you're
going to enjoy this if i need to be
funny i'll be funny on stage yeah we get
jokes and i break his balls
but i want you guys to tap into me and i
tap into you guys once i meet you
and i see the twitter handles and i put
it all together i get you
and i know why we communicate it's a
[__] simplest [__] thing i've ever
seen in my life now i get why you
just something about your personality
something about mine we just click
through the [__] computer that's the
best how crazy is this bro
it's unbelievable
so cool but uh but uh yeah you know
yesterday joey um i was walking into the
gym
and
for some reason as i was opening the
door
i heard your voice pop into my head
and say it's a beautiful day to be alive
and you know i took that with me going
in
and i had
probably
just one of the best workouts i've had
in a while
and
you know it just it just goes to show
that you know the energy that you're
putting out
you know it's hitting us
you know and
you know um
the live podcasts
you know
going to see you at at your shows you
know it you know you're you're really
reaching us
and and it's helping
you guys are reaching me and it's
[__] helping like i said man i'm in a
different [__] zone right now
leith came to see me the other day he
goes that his girlfriend told him that
i've gotten better on stage
it's not that i've gotten better it's
that you guys have made me loving what i
do a lot more
it's not that i got better
i didn't have a reason to be funny
before
i had nothing i had a people going a
bunch of people going to see joe rogan
not who this [__] fat guy was now i
have a reason to go home and write for
you guys i have a reason to throw away
that joke that doesn't work
i have a reason because the love you
guys give me through the [__] wire
i feel it so i have to be my best which
makes out the best in you which means
all of us [__] doing something at
some point in the day
that's we're making conscious of what
the conversation we had
i'm doing it now man i'm doing it
[__] now because of you guys
you know today i got mad at my wife
because she didn't make me spinach
[__] pasta
i really want to get healthy why i have
you guys i have a reason to [__] live
mercy and my wife is a staple i have you
guys you guys are 20 years old and i
come into shows yeah you guys don't even
listen to your [__] fathers
you have no respect for your [__]
families half you because i didn't at
that age i didn't we judged and we
thought that why would i listen to him
he's a [__] loser
but you'll come to a show and talk to me
and tell me hey joey this is what's
going on in my life and i'm [__] so
grateful for that because this will some
way and another make you go back to your
dad or your uncle
it's all connected right now when i was
growing up i had no respect for nobody's
[__] this [__] bump look at me he's a
janitor what the [__] does he know that
guy knows about my life is that anybody
that anybody you know so i appreciate
the love you guys give me lee the
respect you give lee when steve samoan's
in town you know how we do it bray we
ain't [__] around doug what kind of
work do you of course
um well
so right now i'm i'm in between uh i'm
in between jobs you know i moved i moved
out to california last year
for a job
and i got laid off
and uh it it actually
took me
you know almost seven months but i just
found a new job yeah
and uh i actually am moving
again back to the east coast
for uh for this job but uh you know
while while i was
unemployed and while i was
you know looking for jobs i i didn't
want to just you know sit on my ass and
not do anything
so uh i went and i became a certified
personal trainer
and uh you know i because i i eventually
want to do that you know full-time i
really want to dedicate myself full-time
to fitness and
you know helping people
and and that but you know in the
meantime i got to pay the bills so you
know i got to do what i got to do i got
to hustle
but um
you know and and while i was unemployed
you know i got really down a lot you
know and uh you know like i said joey
you know going to those live podcasts uh
it really helped
you know it it helped to laugh
uh you know
steve you know seeing you in irvine it
it helps wow you know um
and
you know it it's it's been a tough road
but you know
there's there's there's light at the end
of the tunnel
and you know um
you know
your job searching
because you don't hear back
a lot of people get really down when
you're job searching
and
you don't you don't hear back you spend
so much time they call you in for
interviews
and you get so excited because it would
be perfect and and you can make this
much money and then you just don't hear
back and then you just don't hear back
it was the thing with with bearcats 10
times yeah i mean yeah it sucked
to to go through that but
it sucks because i've seen a bunch of
people who from my hometown are still
working at the movie theater which could
be cool
but it like you went to school to do
something and you're not even trying to
do it anymore yeah it gets frustrating
it's like
it's hard it's hard not to give up but
it's cool and it eventually pays off
usually if you put the work in
yeah i mean you're lucky if you get a
call back when you when you
apply for anything you know
most of the time you're flying online
and and they don't even see this [__]
never
no
but um brother i'm happy it's only
working out for you my brother i really
am i'm happy that uh
you got a path
i'm happy that you got a little money to
[__] keep food on the table for you
and your family and
you sound great bro
i love you to death thank you see you
harry i love you guys so uh take care be
good and
and uh
and i'll keep uh i'll keep it i'll keep
it going
bro
you got my heart and come up here and
give [__] lee a free training session
and we'll put you on the [__] thing
and talk about it and [__] all right
all right sounds good that'd be awesome
good luck to you whatever you want to do
you got this bite thank you
thank you good good good luck um
you know i know you're looking to do
this surgery and and you know if you do
do it you know good luck to you man you
know
brother all right i love you guys have a
good night papa
thanks for hanging out in irvine harry i
remember him it's uh
you know when you talk to
these guys you know
and when you see him on it shows this is
different years ago i didn't want to go
on the road now i can't wait to meet
people yeah we're going to bump into
yeah who i'm going to bump into
absolutely you know like the online when
i saw jason no susquehanna
you know i [__] saw him and i was
like oh my god
you know i kept looking at him and i'm
like this [__] used to bring
bags of edibles shopping bags
of edibles thank god he didn't bring one
tonight he probably had a pound on him
he probably was dying to give me one i
love these guys this is the this is the
while you go on the road and now i've
been to buffalo twice i see the same
people my man damar
you know i go to these towns and you see
and you start building now i'm gonna
have bad shade when i go back i can go
to lunch you're back and all the [__]
you know so just thank you people for
being who the [__] you are this is easy
for me
this has been great for me and lee and
we started at six in the morning for a
while we were young and screaming over
there then we were in an office
this has always been easy for me i told
my wife and i go you know what
i didn't want to get pissed off at
somebody when they [__] with my wife
or when they mess with the podcast and
infuriates me because this is our baby
this is what
this is all lee and i have this is it
this is it lee without this he's got
paula and after four weeks paulie gonna
put up with his [__] little jew dick
and not eat her ass during the super
bowl with no work she knows that he
knows that who's on the phone sucker
what's up my brother or sister yo yo yo
yo what's up where you at
hey man i'm in tennessee look at you you
bad [__] where you close to
nashville of memphis uh close to
nashville a couple cities south what's
the name of jackson
uh columbia
columbia i've never been there but i
heard of columbia very nice what kind of
work you do over there tennessee
um just recently quit my job worked at
uh kroger's for eight years
about to move back to california got my
pops he ain't doing too well uh decided
i'm gonna move back home where you going
what part of cali does your dad live in
uh he lives in the bay area okay look at
you that's a good [__] area
yeah i grew up there i was from there
born and raised
how the [__] did you end up in kruger's
in
tennessee um
basically
my uncle
my dad's brother i was very close with
him i used to go to his house just about
every weekend we're very close i look at
him like an older brother type of deal
and he decided he was going to move to
tennessee with his wife and his kids to
start a new family out there and just
just you know
experience life and i decided i was
going to go you know cross country with
him
got out there
liked it told him uh i'm a this was a
my junior year summertime going into uh
my senior year so i told them i was
gonna fly back to california
graduate and then once i graduated i
flew out to tennessee and i've been out
here ever since wow
you're a bad [__] tennessee
tuxedo
so how long have you been dealing with
who last place
it's a what
it's a cool ass place to live very laid
back you like it you like you like you
go to nashville a lot drink and party in
nashville no
back in the day i used to i got into a i
got into a brawl at a club and i ain't
been doing that [__] since so
okay so you learned your lesson
yeah learned the hard way um what kind
of work you're gonna be doing in the bay
area
um right now i don't know i got a lot of
friends out there i'm talking to trying
to hook up with i got people that work
with uh
the tesla company oh cool i got people i
mean i got people that are working all
over like i'm trying to get jobs through
mainly i want to work at whole foods
because i've already got
the grocery experience
working at kroger's right here so
i like whole foods i like the whole
organic the whole healthy you know part
of it so i'm trying to that's that
that's my first uh
place i want to work at what is your
specialty produce
yep produce i was an assistant post
manager for closure that's great that's
what i'm talking about this [__]
that was a good apple you know what i'm
saying you ain't [__] i'm pretty sure
take that [__] apple back [__] suck i
see you listening
yeah i call that [__] check that
[__] out take that [__] swarm
out of that
i'm happy bro i'm happy you're making a
change
it gets cold in tennessee this time of
year right brother
uh
usually yeah this uh this winter's been
a little bit warmer it hasn't snowed as
much you know it don't smell like where
you're from you know east coast or
nothing but
you know it's been a it's been a mild
winter
all right
it's it's only february 2nd don't get
too [__] comfy don't put the hundreds
in the bay area living like a [__]
doctor so
when are you leaving what are you
worried about
when are you leaving
um my dad uh he's got
he's got stage three bladder cancer he's
about to have a surgery march 2nd so
anytime this month i'm leaving so
brother good luck to you uh i know you
got a big chore up there being with your
dad you're gonna take care of them
i'm happy that you're doing that man
that's always great for him you know his
final month so maybe he'll pull him out
of it or
maybe yeah i want to be there for him
you know i just it just i flew back for
his birthday in november and he just
started his chemo he looked
he looked he didn't look right you know
and see my family my mom you know she
was taking it very bad my sister you
know my grandmother everybody you know
and i'm back in tennessee so i was just
like man
yeah
i i gotta go back
sometimes the family calls brother
that's the bay area you got nothing to
lose my brother good luck to you
thank you for listening man hey i just
want to say man that uh just like all
these other callers have called up and
and and congratulated just you just say
that how good of a person you are the
things you talk about how you inspire
people man i'm not gonna lie there's
been times in my work where i wanted to
[__] quit
and i put on your podcast and listen to
you and it just stupid [__] you say just
makes me laugh or whatever and it just
it just the little things like that make
my day better and i it's easy for me to
the rest of my day i just i don't know
i'm just it makes you better man and i
just
for everyone else man that that's
listening they feel the same [__] dude
and i speak for them and i say thank you
and keep doing what you're [__] doing
man hope to hope to see you on these
bigger movies and you know doing bigger
things later on man i love you brother
i'll see you up at the bay area this
summer all right man you coming to san
jose man i'm gonna come check you out
god bless your father i hope everything
goes well brother i love you
hi family gotcha brother
take care man again my brother
what do you think of that lisa you're
[__] sitting there like
[__]
so much love tonight joey this is great
this is why i wanted to do this just to
talk let people know where they're at
where we're [__] that one more call
okay
one more call i love you what's
happening over here
joey diaz check it out listen listen
oh [__]
that's the reefer compartment right
there what's going on my brother oh joey
it is good to talk to you lee good
seeing you hey buddy what's your name
i'm casey seifer from pittsburgh kansas
oh [__]
[__] kids
and he won the game tonight kansas
played kansas state saturday night
sunday night and it was on oh [__] i i
have no idea just all these patriots won
in the super bowl
what do you think yeah i worked really
hard this year what are you close to
brother over there in kansas what big
cities uh
you know where uh joplin missouri is no
i've never been there i don't know
lawrence that's as close as it gets
maybe uh tulsa okay oklahoma i'm going
to oklahoma this year
nice yeah
hell yeah like in may or something i'm
going to oklahoma some theater that's
bringing people in oh that's great once
a month or something that's a part of me
[__] dynamite like todd barry
everybody who's done it's like [__]
this is cracking so that's great what's
up with you oklahoma what kind of work
you do over there kansas
i'm actually a farm labor right now
driving tractors and helping out there
where i can but i'm actually going to
pittsburgh state university studying
some psychology at the moment when are
you leaving
what was that oh you're going to
pittsburgh st i'm so sorry this [__]
gummy bear no you're a kid yeah i'm a
junior over there okay and when do you
graduate
may of uh next year 2016. look at you so
you're working full-time at a farm
and then going to psychology school
that's what i'm supposed to do in
college that's what people do that's
crazy
you think everybody sits around and fans
that [__] and waits for a bird
this is what you do when you're in
college you know you had a job at
[__] cvs yeah you went to school who
the [__] who the [__] is this or is that
you lee yeah
who is that it's paul let me guess who
the [__] is that i didn't answer it tell
her goodbye go to bed tell her go to bed
[__] sucker
what's happening brother see what i
gotta live with
she knows what the [__] you're feeling
vibrated i know my phone has not
vibrated at all nobody calls me this
late they know better [__]
[__] tell them you always get close
tell a good night it's over i'm calling
tomorrow morning i'm too high to [__]
talk
i don't want to talk about law school
today
sorry about that and get really
interrupted by [__] lisa over here
kansas no i know
you guys are my heroes man you guys
every morning i love it you guys give me
motivation when i go to school i get
down it's i get burned out you know just
studying all the time and i get that
wake up [__] in the morning man
it's awesome you got to wake up
[__] and i like how people respond
to it because they know that's the
bottom line you got to wake up
[__] what what
what's with the [__] procrastination
yeah what is 10 more minutes gonna do
for you nothing what is 10 minutes gonna
[__] do for you another 10. get up
come on
chomp choppy watch that [__] get there
on time with a smile on your face
what's better who's better than you
nobody
right lisa you're right kansas in the
[__] house i love it
josh that's right man i love you guys
stevie hey what's up don't want to
forget about i want you guys to take it
easy all right all right god bless
love you brother thank you very much for
calling my friend we'll see you joey
thank you in oklahoma
hell yeah i'll see you there bring
reefer don't forget about it
20 for everybody come on brother bring
reefer [__] sucker bring rolling papers
people forget
all right you guys take it easy all
right brother let me give a shout out to
the sponsors i i'm gonna do these shows
more often wonderful
because i get to talk to you guys and i
gotta spread this form i gotta figure
out how to make it even more
once we get the roku things and
everything going we're gonna [__]
rock your motherfucker's world all right
we ain't [__] around here i love
doing this i love
monday nights i like putting together
something thursday you know lee and i
were talking about doing something maybe
friday after i don't know this is how
much we love doing this communicate with
you guys so please be patient with us
we're only going to get better and
better and better and better and to get
better you got to start with honor [__]
suckers not to be a [__] [__] segway
or nothing let's cut through the
[__] you want abdomen optimization
this is the way to get it go to
honor.com right now and look at that
tremendous [__] supply of different
products from shrew tech to shrink tech
[__] sport to the hct oil with the
coconut [__] thing in it
the sweet and stuff plus the flagship
alpha brain you know what i'm saying if
you went on a date with a chicken her
[__] was missing would you call her
back for the second date no she's got no
alpha bringing that monkey put out go
the [__] island right now all the
alpha brain it's got a back guarantee if
you don't focus better if you're not
[__]
firing on all cylinders we're sending
your money back we know you want the
[__] product that's how we roll all
right i love your dad go to honor.com
and press in church oh [__]
ch and put some bass in your voice
you are ch
i got 10 percent off your first order
you also have the stay on it program we
could deliver right to your house
monthly you'll need to order oh gods
also to my favorite people in the
[__] world
iron dragon irondragontv.com you
understand me you want [__] roku you
want [__] kung fu movies iron dragons
the way to go classic lip man early
jackie shan [__] all that ancient
stuff you see from china you learn how
to do [__] mystical stuff fly through
the air with [__] a four [__] fl
the four straw bow the guy that won the
episode
had the [__] bow in it and [__] this
is what i'm talking about if you know
about stuff like that cut this [__] go
to iron dragon tv and press in joey oh
[__] i get two not one free rental but
[__] two okay you make up your mind
after that we ain't [__] around and
dave foley's adding new [__] every
[__] week as soon as he gets it
direct from china this ain't no [__]
dave foley goes deep into the jungles of
[__] china and bangkok
and he has to [__] fight [__] 20
[__] people and stab a [__]
and pay a half a million to bring you
these [__] kung fu classic films so
just look at me and go hahaha [__] you
go to iron dragon tv and press in joey
and get two free films on the [__]
uncle joey all right
that's how we [__] cook somebody's
[__] trying to kill themselves they
smell [__] yes yes where's robert
williams
86.com you bad [__] right here
the cigar of the year right here
anything.com hit a home run with this
[__]
i love everything they do to me this is
their flagship this [__] hideous
thing cigar you know how many weeks you
can smoke this [__] every night let's
say you want to vegas you can blow smoke
in people's faces every night for about
a month
deep you understand me plus you're
looking to quit cigarettes they also
have the nicotine [__] thing
milligrams 16 milligrams eight
milligrams and zero milligrams to you
quit smoking go to headysigs.com and
press in joey's church joey's church at
20 off your [__] first thought all
right that's how we wrote what are you
giggling about if i had a knife
i'd throw it at you and i'd make it cut
you like that
little white kid road warrior remember
when he had the balloon
at the boomerang
and also don't forget the premier pen in
the vapor world
nailed it live.com if you want to
[__] smoke vapers and get blow
torches and all that [__] this is the
website for you go to naildonlife.com
and press enter
oh [__] [__] and you got twenty
percent off your first thought i went on
nailedthelife.com the other day the
webpage they got tons of [__] going in
there daily weekly i love these [__]
people i love all that stuff they got
the long sticks the dab they got it all
go to nailedthelife.com.com
irondragontv.com and honey.com if you
want to support the podcast and without
that i'll do i'll see you [__]
next week
in austin texas [__] lee ain't coming
down it it's me and mario brzezinski
whatever crazy name is my friend from
philly where are you at next week steve
somebody edmonton canada that's what i'm
talking about this is what i'm [__]
talking about we're reaching you
[__] we're like tentacles you
understand me with like dog [__] like
puerto ricans were everywhere
that squad could be in edmonton ahri
could be in chicago
i could be somewhere i don't go
international i got problems
besides you know what the [__] i'm
talking about i love you [__] the
church for life you bad [__]
thank you for calling in thank you for
taking the time thank you for [__]
making me a better [__] savage lisa
don't just sit there hit it
all right
all right look
we were flowing i think they bump into a
[__] bump in the roads
sleeping you did this to me i didn't do
nothing go to honda.com church to get 10
off of your order
go to netherlife.com and use cardboard
joey diaz to get 20 off the premier
vapor pen on the market for oil and wax
mo for the oil and wax markers out there
go to hit e6 dot com and use cover
joey's church to get 20 off of your
first order proof is in the vape
um it's 20 percent off for your first
part if you need to get easter guards
and e-cigarettes and go to iron dragon
tv and use code joey to get 20 off of
your order no not two free rental